how's it going brahs today we're gonna
play and a game big surprise I know but
it's not just any game this one's called
angry Henry so we have suze chainsaw
cannon or laser shotgun laser shotgun
please yes
oh god no there's so much going on how
am I supposed to keep up with that Oh No
whatever that is no god damn this game
is badass what the [ __ ] are those bats
they look like condoms look at my
aim-down-sight thing whoa did you see
that no why hey the stream just tried to
do a jump ball you are midair screaming
pushes enemies away no way so me
screaming actually helps the game that's
why I didn't die before I love the
clouds they're so kawaii you'd think a
game like this is like made for me and
oh yeah you got don't bother those
glasses look like bolts how about that
that's right I think I think they just
made up the screaming part just to make
me look like an idiot yes we can yes we
can yes no no
how many of them can fit in I will not
lose here no I wore some man with balls
on my face no I'd you that's you [ __ ]
come on yes yes how much happy as the
clouds just gotta get that jumping game
on look at this [ __ ]
that's impossible this game wants me to
do the impossible
going down mr. Pope there's no hope for
the Pope oh oh oh oh damn Jesus Christ
sorry Pope I didn't mean that one okay
all right looking good why there's have
to be so many banana bits ah that's
right be gone chiffon upset done ah
I'll [ __ ] me then no no no no no nein
nein nein nein nein nein petition break
the fleet this year mother
fine pulling it up and all of my hate
all of my eggs
suck my ass senpai please every Tuesday
or my nipples get too moist and I have
to go to the doctor because he Miles's
them nicely and [ __ ]
don't know with the forecast
laughs yes good
we have walrus and we have mom copter
and then one more I'll leave that one to
next one if you want me to play please
don't like this video it's a school I
have returned from the gates of Hell to
finish angry Henry
we beat Dave copter we beat Pope cobster
we can beat the walrus copter here we go
watch me do it first try ah how was I
supposed to do anything in my life
you go down walrus you gonna a shop in a
bullet but it's kept at about a meter
but everybody made a minute ago me I
gotta go below I'm angry Henry bigger
bang BAM Baba same vice ass will be
sucked there are not the condom bats not
the [ __ ] conscious why why was the
night why is it : here they must be
something in the atmosphere this is not
me I shouldn't be so angry over video
games except this is not a video game
it's a [ __ ] hell hole pretty hell of
a day Oh
Deutschland Deutschland Deutschland
Deutschland
oh there we go here we go I'm not a ho
I'm a bro don't you know you [ __ ]
plateau I will suck on your toe all
night low baby Oh what happened this
time I will do it for you bros you
flappity boo you i clicked
i swerve dude how will i suck some pies
ass if senpai doesn't have one me at
wikibook you can why he'll bet that oh
it's gonna happen
I don't give a [ __ ] hmm why won't
he
yes yes please please please you don't
see I think we're gonna end it there a
big deal it's just a video game
next time we're gonna kill walrus and
we're gonna come for my mom
god damn it leave a like for part 2 and
I will see you in my shoe